congratulations you just won american
idol what
yeah has it sunk in yet no
no
no
noah thompson
[Applause]
tell me what you're feeling right now i
am in complete shock i don't i really
don't know how to feel like i was on
that stage and they said my name it just
blew me away i just yeah yeah leah told
me that you're essentially saying your
goodbyes every week and here you are all
the way at the end i mean you really
truly didn't expect this did you no not
at all no i've been saying since the
beginning they all know how i was about
that i mean it's been an amazing process
it's all been so much fun but
i never thought i was going to go
through you know so this is crazy man it
just goes to show you you really
resonated with audiences out there
what's it like to now be building this
fan base you know and what are you most
looking forward to in the future
man just
kind of looking forward to going back
home and just just uh taking it all in
for a second you know i mean processing
and
really just building from this because
this is crazy i just did not expect this
whatsoever you deserved it i can tell
you're still trying to like even fathom
the idea that you're american yeah i
don't know what to do right now
[Music]
well the good news is your family's here
what did it mean to have your grandma
here and also your son right yeah it
meant the world it meant the world to
have them all there i had my buddy dylan
and his wife here
you know it was awesome have you thought
about your son maybe one day watching
you on idle on youtube in the future
what's that going to be like that for me
that's the biggest thing of all this
because uh you know i wanted to do this
for him and i remember looking up to my
dad that way you know so maybe
i think that's the best part about this
whole process i think that's what's cool
about it and finally i mean you got to
perform for lionel richie katy perry and
luke bryan week after week what's the
one piece of advice that you're going to
carry with you throughout the rest of
your career they've given me a lot of
advice
he told me to step out on that stage for
the rest of my life
on the stage and i never forgot that so
and it's only the beginning so enjoy the
ride sir and congratulations
[Music]
you